The stunts in this series
were performed as supervised
by professionals.
Do not attempt any of the
stunts you are about to see.
Hi, I'm Stephen Tries,
and welcome to my new show,
Stephen Tries Stunning C***.
Sorry, Stephen Tries
Cunning Stunts.
The show which sees me,
Stephen,
trying to recreate stunts
from your favourite
Netflix movies
with the help
of some of Hollywood's
finest stunt performers.
Today, I'm going to be
setting myself on fire.
And I know
what you're thinking.
"Stephen,
your comedy's so good,
aren't you always on fire?"
And you'd be
absolutely right.
But it's time
for the roast master
to get a taste
of his own medicine.
Cut there.
I'm not actually gonna be
setting myself on fire.
I've given my mate Max £40.
He's gonna be
my stunt double.
Max, come on out!
Meet the stunt team.
You Cupid stunt.
Max…
Max, are you OK?
Can we still
set him on fire?
No.
Max, can you move your arms?
Good.
So in the words
of Take That,
let's relight my fire,
shall we?
Why am I being set on fire?
I hear you ask.
Because in this absolutely
terrifying scene
from Project Power,
we see Machine Gun Kelly
ablaze.
World-famous stunt
coordinator Justin Pearson
told me to meet him
in some random warehouse
to show me how it's done.
A strange location
as I'm only used to being
on fire in the bedroom
or badminton court.
Either way, my PE teacher
taught me everything I know.
Ah, Justin.
Can I call you
"Thrustin' Justin"?
-No, you can't.
-OK, JP.
What are we doing
here today?
Well, Stephen,
we're gonna set you on fire.
You've seen the clip,
Project Power,
a combination of flame,
practical effects,
and visual effects.
So, we're not just
gonna set you on fire.
We're gonna set
an arm on fire,
then we'll go to your legs,
and then we'll finish up
with your back on fire,
which is a bit bigger flame.
Ooh, lovely.
In fact, wait there.
I'll show you.
OK, Justin.
Lighting in three, two, one.
This was terrifying.
I hadn't seen a man
that fired up
since I ran for Year Seven
school council.
Right, Stephen, what did
you think of that then?
It's frightening.
You know,
Bonfire Night gone wrong
was the sort of vibe
I got from it.
OK, you ready
to do some stuff?
-Yeah. Yeah, sure. Yeah.
-Excellent. OK.
Well, first of all,
meet the stunt team.
You got Barry.
-Hi, Barry.
-He's on gluing.
And then, you got Dan.
-Dan was the guy on fire.
-Yeah, he did a great job.
We'll do a few
dry rehearsals.
If we stand you on here,
this will be
your first position.
And this is where
we put the paste.
-The glue.
-Yeah.
This is the product
we set fire to.
If you put your arm out,
we're gonna start off,
we're going
to set fire to your arm.
-Yeah.
-Which is from here to here.
As an extra
safety precaution,
I decided to try
and put out the flames
with my own sweat.
So, Baz will paste you up.
What have I done wrong, Baz?
So, the cue to move
to here is "move".
-Good. Makes sense.
-Yep.
Dan will come in
with some alcohol IPA,
which is a spritz.
So, at this point,
when you hear the count,
start holding your breath.
It's a breath-holding
exercise.
So, hold your breath.
Three, two, one. Go.
Move forward.
You can start moving
your arm about a bit.
You can look at it.
Get your head away from it.
Okay, maybe do
a little twist for us.
-Like that? Oh, yeah.
-Yeah, that's it.
When you get to this line,
go straight down,
still holding your breath.
The boys will come in
with the CO2.
When you hear
the word "out",
we know the flame
has been extinguished,
and then, you can stop
holding your breath.
Lovely.
OK?
Any questions with that?
Before, when you said
Barry's on glue,
did you mean that stuff or…?
No, just Barry's on glue.
Lighting in three, two, one.
Go.
Arm's on fire.
You're looking at it.
Yeah.
Out!
So far, I look less
like an action hero,
and more like
an air hostess gone rogue.
-OK, so that's the arm burn.
-Yeah.
We're now going
to do the next burn,
which is the back
of your lower legs.
Lighting in three, two, one.
Go.
Move forward.
Three, two, one. Go.
At this point,
I decided to show what
it would have looked like
if Max had been
my stunt double.
Nice full twist there,
mate, I think.
Yeah.
Yeah. Good, good, good.
-Perfect. Well done, mate.
-Easy.
-Easy with no flame, yeah?
-Yeah.
We can just edit that in.
That's fine.
I've got the routine,
though.
-You've got the routine?
-Yeah.
What an afternoon.
Can't beat it.
Oh, Millie.
I was sent to the caravan
to rub protective lubricant
all over my body.
If you want to see
what that looks like,
go to Bognor Regis
on Valentine's Day.
That's a stiff nipple.
Did somebody
call the Fire Police?
-Brigade!
-Brigade?
I was nervous.
A YouTuber hadn't
been this blazed
since wroetoshaw's birthday.
So, Stephen,
it's getting real now.
How'd you feel?
Warm and a little bit cold,
and real mixed emotions
going on here.
So, you've got one layer
of wet Nomex
close to your skin.
You've got
a second layer of…
As Justin did his best
Gok Wan impression,
I couldn't help but wonder
if the flame-resistant thong
I'd been given
was actually necessary.
OK, I think you're ready.
Yeah, I'm ready
for the real thing.
Yep. Should we do it?
-Yeah, let's go for it.
-Let's do it.
There was no
turning back now.
I was trusting Justin
to stop me from combusting.
Paste.
Move.
Spritz.
Lighting.
Three, two,
one.
My arm was on fire,
something I had often
experienced
in my teenage years.
Out.
Now, that's what
I call hot pants.
As the crowd went wild
for my barbecued buttocks,
I knew there was one
more stunt to go.
Lighting.
Three.
Two.
One.
As I reached
the final strait
of Justin's baptism of fire,
flames lapping
around my neck,
it dawned on me that could
have earned a lot more money
doing a BPM brand deal.
I haven't felt this hot
since I bought my first
pair of jean shorts.
Anyway, this is
Stephen Tries sounding out
from what feels like
the burning depths of hell.
I'll see you soon
on another episode
of Stephen Tries
Cunning Stunts.
Make sure you like
and subscribe
for some more hot content.